foreign
[Music]
once took advantage
I learned my lessons
I aimed some small parts of my mental
capacity back in my own Direction and
now gravity itself serves my whims you
must find counter Earth familiar counter
Earth I visited your planet many years
ago Earth hasn't been my planet in a
long time you know people had
wonderful spirit the art and music and
literature were some of the finests in
the universe
Earth would be a fabulous place for it
not for the ignorance and bigotry okay
it inspired me to create counter-up I
don't care all of the good and none of
the bad I don't need another speech by
some impotent whack job whose mother
didn't love him rationalizing why he
needs to conquer the universe I'm not
trying to conquer the universe
affecting it
[Music]
let me tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
[Applause]
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
thank you
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
and a beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into nothing
knock it off what
or notice how black your eyes were they
were replaced by my father as a method
of torture he he picked a pretty set
[Music]